Mass incarceration means that we've got a very high rate of incarceration...
...historically, comparatively and the other thing is the rate of...
...incarceration is so high, so socially concentrated,...
...that we're no longer incarcerating the individual, that we're incarcerating whole social groups.
The rate of incarceration now is about five times higher than it was historically.
Historically, it was a hundred per hundred thousand.
Now, it's about five hundred per hundred thousand if we look at prison.
If we add jail to that it's about seven hundred per hundred thousand.
Nowhere in the world incarcerates as much as we do.
We've seen extremely high rates of exposure to the criminal justice system...
... for African-American men with very low levels of schooling.
So, if we think about black men who were born in the late...
...1970s and who are growing up through the American prison boom of the 1980s...
... and the 1990s, the chances that they're going to serve time in state or federal prison...
...if they dropped out of high school is about 70 percent.
So, going to prison for that group of black men with very low levels...
...of schooling, that's become a normal life event.
That's really only happened in the last ten years.